[Music]
Heroes it's an oldfashioned Den
notion but the world can still use
them ready whatever it takes whatever it
takes we destroyed
Thanos but it's not over my work is
inevitable there will always be
more to finish that
this is just the
beginning she tore a hole in
space there's a different
reality leading into
[Music]
ours what are you prepared to do I'm
rful your powers only make me stronger
see you can't be
[Music]
matched can't be
control I'm
asking for one last
[Music]
fight
mon you cannot protect your
people but you can stand on without
standing
alone they're
[Music]
here the marveles r
PG-13 uhoh Monica you got to fly no no
no like your
magic in Peters Friday get tickets
now
[Music]